foreign
nice to be here
yeah let's all take our seats and we can
start this Powerhouse panel of women we
are the 50 percent
all right and just one request please
that you don't walk around during
because this is a beautiful uh set of
cameras and angles and we don't want
these ladies obscured by people's heads
right
I think we're ready all right may I
please welcome Ursula Wonderland
president of the European commission and
Santa Marin prime minister of Finland
welcome
[Applause]
start by putting it in context and
asking a little bit of an atmospheric
question you both assumed office were
elected to your positions in December of
2019 shortly thereafter the world
changed we first had the covid pandemic
especially on the line and both of you
actually did you ever imagine that you
would be involved and we're just talking
about covid now in such a global
upheaval when you first took the job of
course not I had no clue of what was
coming up
um indeed I came into office in December
2019 so I had 90 days and then the who
declared the covet as a global pandemic
with all the consequences behind it
we started actually I started my mandate
with one big priority and that is the
European green deal and digitalization
in hindsight it's still the big topic
behind all these crises but of course
then you have to deal with the pandemic
you have to deal with an atrocious
Russian war in Ukraine so we do not
change the direction of travel but the
speed and the challenges of course I had
no clue what was coming up and prime
minister you you came into office also
in December 2019.
as the youngest prime minister in the
world at the time yes I'm not sure am I
still the youngest prime minister
Sebastian Kurtz was a
some some part of this term a prime
minister a bit younger than me and
actually I just visited Austria
yesterday and and I can remember the
good corporation that that we had
um I must say that we didn't know what
was happening uh 2020 2021
2022 and the world isn't a very pretty
place when looking back and looking at
present and also unfortunately looking
to the Future the first Global pandemic
hit and it changed our security
environment in many ways and we had to
make decisions that we thought that we
could not do but we had to do those then
the war in Europe energy crisis and we
are still in the midst of war and in the
future we are still heading to watch our
biggest challenges climate change loss
of biodiversity and as Ursula said we
have to tackle these problems together
and if you may Ursula I want to give a
little praise to you I cannot imagine
better president for the EU commission
during these difficult difficult times
Ursula has been real Power Player it's
been an honor to work with you thank you
thank you
can I ask you something I'm going to
jump off from the last intervention in
the previous panel which I suppose one
can call Global South
and Ambassador when he opened this uh
this conference said one of the huge
challenges not just for the conference
but for the world and for policy is to
get a much wider public consensus around
the world you heard the vice president
of Colombia uh essentially questioning
the direction of flow and I just wonder
whether you think
that the inability to create equality
and Equity during the pandemic that the
global south felt totally cut off that
they didn't get the vaccines in the same
way that the rich North did I wonder if
you both look back at that despite your
efforts and wonder whether that might
have contributed into Alia to some of
the lack of support you have around the
world for your Ukraine policy
I think should I start my dear yeah I
think
it is important that we're very clear
about what this Russian war is it is
about Putin's imperialistic plans
and this is something where all of us
and mainly the global South have a very
clear idea it is completely unacceptable
and
countries on the other side of the
Mediterranean have a bitter and
long-standing experience first you send
your negotiators in then you send the
they see that the experts are sending
this are being sent in and then it's a
mercenaries that are being sent in so
what we have to do is not only explain
that we will never ever accept this
imperialistic war we will never ever
accept that Putin is trampling on the
international law that protects all of
us
that the U.N Charter that is also in the
interest I mean it's in the interest of
every single country is being treated so
disrespectful and that we will never
accept that today you can send tanks
just across the border to invade a
country
and this is something which my
experience in the last 12 months needs a
lot of just hard work to work together
with as you said the global South to
make understood our point of view but
also to work with them on dealing with
the knock-on effect of this atrocious
War this is the food crisis this is the
energy crisis and that we do our utmost
to
um to to deal with the knock-on effects
in a way that the global South does not
suffer too much from Putin's war of
aggression this is our task it's hard
work but it's absolutely worth it prime
minister Marin
somebody as cult a hero around the world
as president Lula of Brazil also doesn't
believe in the intervention that you all
have taken in NATO against as you
describe the illegal invasion of one
country by a bigger country so
lion says we will never support this we
understand their historic issues how do
you see trying to convince others of the
justness of your cause
the war in Ukraine it's not only an
issue for Europe it's the issue for the
whole world and that's because there's a
war of values going on authoritarian
countries are raising their heads they
are raising their heads against the
international rule-based order and this
is a problem for everyone when Russia
attacked Ukraine it it violated all the
rules all the agreements it has itself
been committed to before and this is a
problem for everyone because then we
will only see Decades of this kind of
behavior ahead of us if Ukraine doesn't
win the war and if we don't stand behind
our values and the international
rule-based order so I think this is a
larger issue than just issue for Europe
just issue for for Ukraine and we have
to do utmost to make sure that Ukraine
will win and that we will preserve this
system of rules that we have created
together and there was a reason why this
was created the wars before world wars
that we have seen and it was devastating
and that's why we built system where we
can negotiate where can we can build
peace not use uh violence against each
other Wars uh attack another country to
make a stand or or gain something and to
that end when you came into office you I
mean as as early as this time last year
you were saying that Finland would not
want to join NATO and then a month later
was the invasion and now obviously you
have joined you're trying to join NATO
there is a a little bit of a kerfuffle
with turkey deciding whether it's going
to approve or not we understood from the
Secretary General of NATO that maybe now
there will be separate tracks do you
expect to join NATO separately or are
you committed to trying to join it
together with Sweden when the world war
started uh 24 of February last year and
now we're heading towards very sad
anniversary one year anniversary of the
war just next week it was obvious that
Finland will join NATO it was obvious at
the same day when Russia attacked
Ukraine The Finnish mindset the most
important thing for Finnish people is to
make sure that we are independent we are
secure we have a sovereign country we
can make our own decisions this is the
number one issue for Finnish people and
when Russia our neighbor attacked
another neighbor Ukraine it was obvious
that Finland will join NATO because
that's the line that's the only line
that Russia wouldn't cross so it's to do
with our security it's to do with peace
it's the act of Peace for Finland to
join NATO we have sent very clear
message we want to join together with
Sweden at the same time it's not only
because we are good neighbors and good
partners it's also to do with very
concrete matters at the security
planning of NATO in the whole North it's
in interest of us but it's also in the
interest of NATO that Finland and Sweden
will join simultaneously and we have
sent very clear signal and very clear
message to Turkey and also to Hungary
that hasn't ratified yet that we want
enter NATO together and this is in the
interest of everyone so no change then
even if some country no change of course
we cannot influence and affect how some
country would ratify it's their decision
but our message is that we are willing
to join and we prefer and want to join
together
um
[Applause]
do you remember very well this time last
year there was warnings by the United
States and the UK that Putin was
planning an invasion your country
Germany others including the president
of Ukraine who was sitting here did not
want to accept that that was a reality
and basically we're trying to say no we
hope negotiation can work anyway it
didn't
but even then you were saying in your
speech last year and you you used
Ukraine as the Cornerstone you talked
about ukrainians as the new generation
young ukrainians of Democrats around the
world do believe that this unity and
steadfastness in the interim year will
continue can you keep all your fractious
members on board and people 500 million
people in the block
absolutely I'm today more convinced than
I was a year ago but to set the record
straight indeed our American friends uh
way more than a year ago started to do
something completely unprecedented that
they took their intelligence and what
knowledge and put it on the public
market this give us gave us an early
warning and my cabinet and the
commission started to work with the
White House and with the treasury
already in December
on potential sanctions
in case that Russia would invade Ukraine
indeed we all hoped that it would never
happen and we wouldn't ever have to use
these sanctions but it was a tedious
work day and night to align our very
different trade systems to develop
sanctions that are targeted at Advanced
Technologies and goods that are
irreplaceable for Russia and to be
completely synchronized also within the
G7
this made it possible that on day two
day four and day 10 of the invasion we
were able to put on the table very heavy
sanctioned packages so
um there was the early warning of the
United States was helpful and there was
work being done without which we would
not have been so effective a second
point is indeed for me
really touching is the fact how
Europeans and I would say democracies
our friends of course and allies and
partners have immediately understood
that this was serious and it is going to
the core of our existence of course we
have many issues that we discuss but
here from day one on we were standing as
one we were united we are united and if
you look back I mean through all the
crisis we have gone including the energy
crisis and we have mastered it today I
can really say I'm deeply convinced that
we will keep the unity and we will keep
the determination because it's about our
values and our very existence we are
fighting for
looking back three steps first when the
when the war started we were prepared
and the commission was prepared uh
making the sanctions together with all
our allies and we were very spas of
putting those sanctions on place so we
were prepared on that stage that way but
looking back now it was obvious that
Russia will attack we didn't want to
believe it we tried everything that we
could to make a diplomatic solution and
that was of course the right effort to
do to trying to make a diplomatic
solution but looking back it was obvious
that Russia will attack Ukraine they
already used the energy leverage during
that summer during that Autumn they
already used the energy leverage there
was different kind of disruptions with
the energy flows during the year of 2021
they had put their troops in different
places saying that they are only
training Looking Back Now it was obvious
that they were planning this big attack
against Ukraine and then looking way
back to 2014 when the Crimea was invaded
we made a big mistake then we make a big
mistake then together not to react more
strongly if we had acted and reacted
more strongly towards the Crimea then
the war wouldn't happen I think Russia
thought that it would be just like
Crimea just entering Ukraine Ukraine
would give them open welcome it would
last only for a few weeks and Putin
would win very very quickly and easily
the war because we didn't react 2014 and
now we have to learn some lessons on the
current situation and I think the main
lesson is not to be naive we cannot be
naive I listened to the the previous
panel and I agree I also want the world
which is beautiful and good and secure
and we don't have to put money to our
military forces to to our Defense Force
this I also want that world but that
world isn't a reality the only way the
security is the only way to secure the
international rule-based order is to
make sure that Europe and Democratic
countries are strong that we are
investing in our defense capabilities
that we have that leverage and that we
have also that threat uh present that
this authoritarian countries where
Russia is is a terrible example that
they don't use Force because they are
also and they have to think also twice
will they use the force and what will be
the consequences
therefore and this is the question
[Applause]
and we're trying to figure this out what
does winning look like to you all you
all have said very strongly what you've
just said prime minister but what does
winning look like and in for a penny in
for a pound surely surely you have to go
to the very end giving all the support
that Ukraine needs to fight this war for
them and for you
is there are you worried ammunition
production is not up and running like it
should there's some slowness let's say
in get in between requesting weapons and
getting there I know you've done an
incredible job but we're talking about
an offensive we're talking about a war
that yesterday Chancellor Schultz said
could go on for years while zelenski the
president is saying he wants it ended
this year don't you have to double
redouble
treble down on your efforts to end this
in a victory what what does a victory
look like nobody's defined it
well absolutely we have to double down
and we have to continue the really
massive support that is necessary that
this imperialistic cleanse of Putin will
completely fail this is one goal and
that that Ukraine is able to win and
what the military support is concerned
indeed I think it's now the time really
to speed up the production and to scale
up the production of standardized
products that Ukraine needs desperately
for example the standardized
standardized ammunition it cannot be
that we have to wait months and years
till we are able to replenish until
we're able to deliver that to Ukraine
what I thought is that we now take the
European peace facility it is in place
it is there to typically fund that
member states give military equipment to
Ukraine so it's an established body it
has a coordination mechanism with
Ukraine and that we convene the defense
industry of Europe and we very clearly
ask them what is it what you need to
scale up and to speed up standardized
project products I'm not speaking about
the highly complex production of
specific things but the standardized
products like 155 millimeters and
artillery for example
so and we need now to do the same way
we've done during the pandemic there are
two we've said look to the
pharmaceutical companies what is it what
you need to scale up we could think of
for example Advanced purchase agreements
that gives the defense industry the
possibility to invest in production
lines now to be faster and to increase
the amount they can deliver and
therefore it is for us Paramount now to
to support Ukraine in these existential
things
I think the second element we should not
underestimate is the economic security
of Ukraine Ukraine needs to survive
economically and there um it's good that
we now have decided to have a regularly
budget support for Ukraine 1.5 billion
per month by the European Union our
American friends are matching that and I
think the international financial
institution should be should do more for
that also so it is the time to step up
because Ukraine really needs the
material to survive
well what is a win for Ukraine that's
the ukrainians to decide our only job is
to provide all the help that they need
military help I'm I agree fully agree uh
with with President Wonderland that we
need to scale up and speed up the
production of ammunition and and other
military equipment very fastly so that
when we give our equipment our
arterially to Ukraine then we can also
replace that and not be vulnerable in
the upcoming years so I totally agree
with that so we have to of course give
them military aid and also much more
heavier Weaponry that they they have
already received and we have to send a
clear message that we will continue this
as long as it take as long as it takes
as long as it's needed they need
financial help they need humanitarian
help they need help rebuilding already
the infrastructure they are not waiting
end of the war and then building Ukraine
they have to build it every day because
Russia is attacking all the
infrastructure very heavily so we need
to give them help whatever they need and
it's their job to decide what are the
terms that they could agree what are the
the victory points that they need to
receive I think that Russia should leave
and they think that too every territory
but it's their decision okay I think a
very important
headline is always for us nothing about
Ukraine without Ukraine they have to
decide what for them finally is the
point to sit down and then go I mean to
be fair they have laid it out in 10
point plans which is good and which
they've laid it apart I need to go to
audience questions maybe some of these
could be and then I'm going to come back
and ask you a final question so this
this uh session is also entitled the EU
more than the sum of its parts not
exactly sure what that is but if anybody
wants to ask any questions we've got
about maybe seven minutes for questions
uh the lady here
yes you
and please make it a question and not a
speech because we don't have time
president Wonderland Natalie tochi
president vondolian back to the knock-on
effects of the war and in particular the
energy crisis now from a European
standpoint intra-european standpoint
we've done fantastically well over the
last year looking at it globally perhaps
slightly less so in the sense that the
LNG hoarding that many of our countries
have been doing have in a sense
contributed to their energy crisis
looking ahead to the next year what is
it that the EU could be doing more in
order to address that Global energy
crisis yeah
so indeed we should not forget how it
started the energy crisis of course an
over-dependency of the European Union on
Russian fossil fuels without any
question but then it was Putin who
within eight months cut 80 percent of
the pipeline gas supply to the European
Union
um big strategic mistake big because he
thought we he could blackmail us that we
go down on our knees the contrary is the
case because we've now completely
Diversified away from the Russian gas
also thanks to the stepping up of our
friends the United States with LNG
Norway with more pipeline gas but more
important is even that it accelerated
our work in the European green deals so
we have really invested in renewable
energy which is homegrown it gives us
independence and it's clean we have
doubled the additional deployment of
Renewables last year in the European
Union and last year for the very first
time wind and solar delivered more
electricity than than gas did what the
other countries are concerned because
and important is that we keep in mind
that the tightness the energy tightness
of the global market is due to Russia's
invasion in Ukraine we should never
forget that but what indeed other
countries are that suffer also from this
energy crisis what they are concerned
for us is important that our work
together for example with the global
South with Africa is intensified on
investment in infrastructure to have
renewable energy to produce for example
green hydrogen we're working now with
the other side of the Mediterranean
exactly on that one so the big Paradox
of this conflict is if there's an
accelerator for the European green deal
and for Global infrastructure in
renewable energy than it's Putin and
with his atrocious War
yes
my question is to the person of the
council
um
of the commission of course
we were lucky that the United States had
Joe Biden as president when Putin
invaded and that they took the lead on
helping Ukraine
but next time they may be otherwise
engaged in the Far East
um thank you for your leadership in
using Europe's small defense budget for
for supplying Ukraine but shouldn't that
defense budget and Europe's military
capability be much bigger in the future
I think we have to invest more in
defense without any question
um but your insinuation that it might be
possible that we cannot so much work
together with our transatlantic friends
it was very reassuring yesterday I had a
panel with Mitch McConnell and it was
good to hear that he was very clear
about the commitment of the whole of the
United States
to support Ukraine and to fight side by
side with us for the defense of our
values without any question what our
defense capabilities are concerned of
course it's Sovereign decisions of the
member states but indeed we have
progressed a lot in the European Union
what
harmonizing of the approach to the
defense capability capabilities is
concerned it has very weird names
acronyms like Pesco light card you name
it but this is good thanks God we have
evident place we can build on that one
but yes the emphasis has to be on a
stronger defense posture
prime minister Marion do you think your
country your people your policies
because it's you who have to do that
it's each country that has to decide
right are you ready because we heard
that the peace dividend uh-uh we're out
of that that time now
your defense budgets have to be ramped
up
well actually if Finland has always
invested heavily on defense because we
are a next door neighbor to Russia we
are already using up to two percent of
our budget to defense and we will
increase this even more so because we
want to be prepared and actually when we
look back at this war and the energy
crisis that we are in Finland already
versified our Energy Mix way before the
war because we have aggressive neighbor
and we don't want that kind of
dependencies that that many other
countries have had I understand the
logic and it's very logical to build
those very close economic connections
and ties to try to make sure that the
war wouldn't happen because we have such
a close Choice it would be so costly
that that we couldn't then see these
kind of uh devastating things happening
but this wasn't the case because the
authority regimes they think differently
and in the future we have to be more
prepared also when it comes for example
sample new technologies and I totally
agree I think United States they will
look towards Asia even more so in the
future and we have to make sure that
that we are not dependent on those
critical matters that we are too
dependent now during the pandemic we
were too dependent on on medicine we
were too dependent on many medical
equipment on the energy crisis we are
too dependent on Russian fossil fuels
luckily and thankfully we have we have
done uh very much to get rid of those
connections
but in the future the big big issue will
be new technologies Technologies know
how knowledge so we have to also invest
in our education system the know-how the
knowledge base and new technologies that
we are not dependent or territory
countries from the East because there
might be dark clouds also in that
direction and if we have those
connections if we are too dependent then
we are also
um
we are
we we cannot be sure that that we are
secure in that perspective as well so
our job is to make sure that our
citizens our societies will cope
whatever happens in the world so we have
to invest European Union has have to
invest and also member states has to
invest more in these critical matters I
I would like to before I before I go to
the audience again if I get some time I
need to ask you both a question about
the 50 this conference is meant to be
you know 50 women maybe it is maybe it
isn't you might have just seen obviously
um Jacinda Arden hugely popular prime
minister of New Zealand resigned citing
she hasn't got any more energy in the
tank Nicholas sturgeon the first
minister of Scotland resigning into Alia
talking about how difficult it is
particularly as a woman to lead any kind
of normal life
um you know as as a as a global leader
um I wonder what you both think about
that because you're the first female in
this position you were the first female
defense minister in your country you've
experienced sexism so just briefly how
do you deal with it what do you think
about their stepping down and how do you
encourage women I know that's a lot but
maybe just a brief a brief sum up and
then I'm going to ask you well first of
all I'm so happy that we live in
countries where leaders change that's a
gift thing
that's all good but if I was targeting
to you I would ask you why did you have
to apologize for being a human being you
have found you know found dancing oh my
goodness how awful yeah you had to
apologize for being a human being why
and I have also danced after that uh
that that one time
[Applause]
um I think there's of course there's a
lot to be done when it comes to gender
equality
um
it's very important that we have people
from different backgrounds different
genders but also different backgrounds
in decision-making places at the same
same table making traditions because
then we have the perspective of everyone
are the 50 of the world so women need to
be 50 of the decision-making making
making uh
bodies I know that that Ursula and the
commission is preparing uh to set a bill
for for companies to have more women
Representatives on the boards of
companies I think this is very important
step forward I think also in the
political system we have to make sure
that women have the possibilities to
step up to have their voices heard there
are a lot of structures within our
political systems that actually prevent
women to get those positions to be heard
many times it's enough that there's one
woman look we have this women here
no problem we have women here no problem
but we need more women and we need
really that 50 to make sure that
everybody's voices are heard so
commissioner I mean president
um why then is it so difficult why do
you have to tolerate so much backlash
misogyny everyday sexism uh all of that
well because they are deep-rooted
unconscious biases but you can
discourage or encourage more well I can
only encourage more women to be on stage
because that's where we belong in the
Limelight and women or men are the one
or the others are not better than the
other but we're different and that's the
point that we have to of course take the
share of the power
to change this world and to improve this
world and I think for that I mean I know
you've done a lot we are doing a lot you
need leadership from the top that is
very important every man on in a top
position every woman in a top position
has to influence
um that there are more women coming
growing up to the top of course it's
also a question of infrastructure so I
vividly remember my most difficult time
where the first years as a minister with
small children
and all these hidden prejudices I got
the question I mean in talks like these
ones have you already decided whether
you want to be a bad mother or a bad
minister so there was this this hidden
Prejudice you cannot be either a good
minister or a good mother if you are a
working one we all know these uh these
prejudices what we have to do is make
sure that the infrastructure is that
there that you have for young couples
support with what is necessary in
kindergarten child care and good schools
we have to make sure that till we have
an equal distribution of men and women
in positions of powers I'm an advocate
for quota that's the reason why we
introduced the quota in Germany that's
the reason why we introduced the quota
now on the European level because the
time till women kind of grow natural
through the ranks naturally through the
ranks is just too long and therefore
still a lot is to do but I can only
recommend to women hang on there because
we need you we need your voice and it's
absolutely important that you're there
I must add
thank you thank you
I must I must add because we are in the
mini security
conference I'm so proud that the former
Finnish Minister for for a defense uh
went to a parental leave
so he he did make that decision to to
want the parental leave because they had
a small child so it's not only a job for
mothers it's also a job for fathers to
take the time to spend it with your
child even though there's war in Europe
even though Finland is joining NATO our
defense minister uh
decided that his child is small only
once and he did take that parental leave
and I'm so happy that this is the
equality in Finland one anecdote if I
make okay they're making me rap but
hurry okay I had decided to have a
gender-based college in the commission
and I have to ask member states to send
me candidates so I told him you sent me
a man and a woman that I can choose my
Commissioners for the college you can't
imagine the outcry on that one there
were member states who sent me three men
to choose from so um in the very end I
have my gender balance college so be
stubborn and stay on the topic then you
will be successful well two great
examples
the commission president Ursula
Wonderland prime minister of Finland
sanamar and thank you very much for
joining
thank you so much
thank you very much that was wonderful
take care
I think so